au moins que Michel à Marseille Aaron un
peu partout à Paris aussi toujours à
pied toujours à pied
Monsieur Joseph Bastianelli fêtait hier
c'est 92 ans il a toujours bon œil mais
surtout bon pied puisque ce sont eux qui
le met le plus sévèrement à l'épreuve il
est vrai que 25 km à couvrir qu'est-ce
que c'est pour qui en a parcouru plus de
5000 en randonnée pédestres ces
dernières années il s'agissait donc
cette fois d'aller de Neussargues à
Saint-Flour sans étape départ à 7 heures
sonnante sous le regard compatissant de
son hôtesse
dès la race campagne et profitant de ce
qu'il ne nous connaissait pas encore
nous avons joué les démonstances afin de
vérifier si Monsieur Bastianelli avait
véritablement le feu sacré
mais
où allez-vous comme ça monsieur à
Saint-Flour mais vous savez qu'il y a
encore 25 km
c'est-à-dire depuis l'Auvergne vous êtes
allé au Mont Saint-Michel à pied retour
à Paris aussi toujours à pied toujours à
pied c'est la rééducation qui a conduit
ce retraité des chemins de fer à se
prouver à lui-même sinon à la France
tout entière qu'il pouvait encore mettre
un pied devant l'autre une fracture du
fémur l'ayant immobilisé au lit une
infirmière novice Nutella goût de
prétendre envisager le massage de ses
membres inférieurs qui pour ankyloser
qu'il soit l'avait en d'autres temps
vaillamment mener au front de la grande
guerre comme de la suivante mieux valait
en conséquence fuir l’hôpital et prendre
la route tout de suite plutôt que subir
cette affront ce qu'il fit au grand dam
de ses médecins qui affirme-t-il paye
aujourd'hui pour avoir un jour voulu le
faire marcher
je faisais quelques ma chaleur et
aujourd'hui j'ai réussi à faire 4 500
alors mais dites moi vous avez le sens
de la publicité chaque étape vous
rencontrez un président de la République
Martin à 73 j'ai rencontré le papa Rhône
maintenant j'espère de rencontrer le
président jusqu'à
Saint-Flour qu'est-ce que vous comptez
lui dire
que je fais des masques pour donner un
exemple
espérons toutefois que Monsieur Giscard
d'Estaing ne sera pas aussi catégorique
que son interlocuteur quant à la
nécessité de généraliser
systématiquement ce moyen de locomotion
saint démocratique et non polluants qui
est la marche à pied
[Musique]